jean marie collin bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france on le disait
c'est donc une première depuis 30 ans le
gouvernement britannique qui va
augmenter le plafond de son arsenal
nucléaire
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est une
conséquence du bric site boris johnson
de l'hiver la semaine dernière vouloir
se détacher de l'union européenne non on
peut pas dire que ce soit une
conséquence du break city a le royaume
uni décide d'augmenter largement son
arsenal nucléaire ça n'a pas de ça n'a
pas de lire le royaume uni intégré ou
pas l'union européenne disposaient d'une
force de dissuasion nucléaire
importantes étaient protégés et à de
l'eau cadre titre de l'article 5 donc
sanaa c'est là aucun lien alors l'on
s'était pourtant engagé il y a dix ans à
réduire son arsenal dans la décennie les
britanniques est ce qui vient le droit
international
alors je voudrais revenir sur ça sur
cette notion d'engagement
en fait c'est pas que londres qui s'est
engagé s'est les cinq puissances qui
possède le plus d'armes nucléaires qui
se sont engagés depuis qu'elles ont
signé et ratifié le traité de non
prolifération nucléaire et notamment
depuis 2010 où elles ont à nouveau pris
cet engagement ferme de diminuer leurs
arsenaux nucléaires et la place de la
dissuasion nucléaire dans leur politique
de sécurité et londres a en plus de ce
qu'ils nucléaire à un niveau à peu près
de 180 au milieu des années 2020
donc c'est un ensemble d'engagements qui
est cassé par londres mais c'est un
ensemble d'engagements qui de toute
façon ne sont pas respectés par les
états qui possèdent des armes nucléaires
alors le premier ministre a justifié
cette décision à une parle d'une hausse
de la menace technologique et doctrinale
peut-être pour comprendre une menace
doctrinal c'est quoi ça signifierait que
les potentiels adversaires donc la
russie et la chine sont prêts à utiliser
plus rapidement ou dans des cas
différents leurs arsenaux nucléaires
s'ils se sentent agressés donc une
utilisation plus plus rapide
et de ce type d'armes de destruction
massive
mais là où on peut être étonné c'est que
ça signifie qu'il faut donc toujours
plus d'armes pour être défendu par
contre ses potentiels adversaires ce qui
signifie bel et bien une nouvelle course
aux armements et ce qui montre bien
aussi la volonté de ces états encore une
fois de londres mais d autres si la
france la russie et les etats-unis et la
chine puisque tous sont dans ce même
dans ce même environnement de moderniser
de renouveler leurs arsenaux nucléaires
de ne pas vouloir aller vers un monde
sans armes nucléaires
est ce qu'on peut y voir derrière
finalement l'impulsion de donald trump
on se souvient il avait commencé non là
où on peut s'arrêter roger c'est que
cette augmentation de sa de cet arsenal
nucléaire s'il est mis un dick et qui
essaie pour faire face à ces changements
doctrinaux potentiels adversaires
on peut s'interroger hosties si ce n'est
pas pour des raisons tout simplement de
coûts ce qui peut paraître un peu
paradoxal c'est à dire que peut-être et
il faut attendre encore incertain de
détail de documents potentiellement
budgétaire peut-être que la production
de plus d'armes nucléaires en fait on
reviendrait moins cher finalement aux
contribuables britanniques que la
production d'un petit nombre d'armes
nucléaires
sachant que ces armes nucléaires sont
aujourd'hui réalisés en commun avec les
états unis
donc on a aussi peut-être sur une
problématique économique ce qui est en
même temps extrêmement paradoxal puisque
la possession d'un arsenal nucléaire
coûte extrêmement cher et plus elles
sont vraiment des chiffres incalculables
voilà vous le soulignez tout à l'heure
le royaume uni désigne la russie comme
une menace majeure
mais le royaume uni se montrent plus
nuancés avec la chine qu est ce qu il
faut comprendre derrière ce
positionnement tout simplement la russie
l'urss d'antan a toujours été
l'adversaire majeur du royaume uni mais
comme de la france ou de l'otan'' la
chine est une est un état nouveau qui
est en train de monter en termes de
capacité de puissance de projection
militaire à travers son arc asiatique et
a potentiellement à travers le monde
mais il paraît assez évident que le
premier adversaire de la chine pourrait
être plus les états unis que londres
mais londres serait forcément tout comme
la france
dyer et l'otage forcément impliqué en
cas de conflit entre les états unis et
la chine
donc il ya toujours un peu un lien de
distance qui était avec la chine même
s'il faut le noter et vous l'avez relevé
que cet état est mentionné dans cette
revue stratégique de défense et de
politique étrangère
tout comme cet état est de plus en plus
nommés dans les documents officiels de
défense de la france et du coup alors
quelles conséquences après cette annonce
du royaume uni est ce que ça va faire
bouger les cartes qu'est ce que ça peut
engendrer des tensions dans les
relations diplomatiques
du coup les conséquences sont
extrêmement graves
c'est la mise en danger du du régime de
non prolifération nucléaire
internationale c'est à dire que ce que
ces états a encore une fois je veux bien
inclure les cinq faut bien côté
spectateurs entendre que ces 5 et à
moderniser renouvellent leurs arsenaux
nucléaires met en danger cette base du
droit international qui a l'a permis de
limiter la prolifération nucléaire qui a
permis d'engager même avec des
difficultés le désarmement notaire et
cette action officielle de londres
puisque on soupçonne fortement la chine
aussi depuis quelques années d'augmenter
son arsenal nucléaire
bah clairement kaas et ce régime et
risque de le mettre en danger et avec
les possibilités d'ouvrir la porte à de
nouveaux états qui souhaitent se doter
de la bombe et de ne plus respecter ce
régime de non prolifération du coeur
c'est pour ça qu'il est important de
sauvegarder le droit c'est pour ça aussi
qu'une majorité c'est l'aspect positif
d'état à travers le monde ont décidé de
ratifier de mettre en oeuvre un traité
pour interdire les armes nucléaires pour
créer une pression pour impliquer la
société civile afin que ces états arrête
tout simplement de mettre en danger la
population internationale
merci beaucoup jean marie collin pour
votre éclairage le rappelle vous êtes
porte parole de la campagne
internationale pour l'abolition des
armes nucléaires
merci